this is Solar Impulse 2 it weighs about
the same as a small car and is powered
exclusively by solar panels the zero
emission plane is currently in Abu Dhabi
before its pilots embark on a 35
thousand kilometer journey that could
secure their place in the record books
we are very modest about the attendant
rewards regime it during ambitious in
the goal that we have the adventure will
span 25 flight days over several months
during which the pilots will take turns
to fly the one-man plane which has
covered in 17,000 solar cells and has a
maximum speed of 140 km/h the route will
take off from Abu Dhabi in March
returning late July via a number of
stops along the way and energy company
Mazda has provided a core team of
technicians and assistance from Abu
Dhabi institutions there's a very clear
demonstration of our common vision our
shared interests and our commitment to
helping advance just such promising
sophisticated
and it's this emissions-free technology
that could be the solution to climate
change and an answer to man's quest for
sustainability